combien d'années vous sépare 28 28 ans
des cas vous êtes ensemble ça a fait un
16 ans ces gens pourraient être
rencontrés à quel âge en fait nuit avec
elle c'était un primaire
merci jean marie l'adea ces problèmes
comme ça
ces rencontres et j'avais 24 ans
d'accord et lui donc il vit l'un avait
52 puisque je suis un petit peu calculé
voilà donc 24 ans cinquante deux ans et
c'est vrai que ça tient de saison vous
avez même eu des enfants sont là deux
ans le sens exactement j'ai eu les baies
l'arrière bravo et merci
c'est vrai et e est ce que vous avez
senti des gens qui vous regardent et
avec dédain qui n'hésite pas possible
c'est trop de différence d'âge je sais
c'est n'importe quoi ou pas du tout oui
bien sûr de toute façon les différents
stages en fait elles ont toujours
dérangé les gens je pense parce que
ça fascine autant que ça dérange j'ai
l'impression que c'est à dire que comme
on n'est pas dans la norme sociale on
est pointé du doigt parce que quelque
part on désobéit à un certain modèle
qu'on nous vend depuis depuis toujours
donc dès qu on désobéit bas on est
pointé du doigt donc évidemment quand
j'avais 24 ans et lui 52 c'était pas
forcément très bien interprété mais de
la même manière que maintenant alors que
on a deux enfants que j'ai quand même 38
ans donc je pas une gamine effectivement
lui ils vieillissent normale et d'un
risque forcément y donner la mort
seulement il a toujours ses 28 ans
d'écart avec moi mais il ya toujours
il ya toujours ce voile à ce malaise
alors et dans votre famille notre
famille a été accueillie comment alors
dans ma famille est ce que c'est ça
aussi ouais alors ce qui est incroyable
c'est que ma maman quand j'ai rencontré
jean marie elle a rencontré son
compagnon avec qui elle est toujours l à
112 ans d'écart
ils ont 24 ans d'écart savoir que lui il
est plus jeune qu'elle de dans quatre
ans donc on a tout fait à l'envers maman
nous a fait penser à switcher
way va peut-être faire ça j'en remets
donc
finir en anglais alors et donc hawaii
tout cas là elle est là qu un garçon
plus jeune belle et oui ils sont fous
amoureux ils n'ont plus aucun pour le
mière inconditionnels donc en fait dans
ma famille du côté de maman ça a été
très bien accueilli mon père un petit
peu moins parce que mon père il m'a eu à
18 ans ouais donc
forcément il est plus jeune que jean
marie a oui c'est vrai donc c'est assez
spectaculaire show fait le calcul il a
56 ans ya dix ans - ouais vous êtes beau
matin moi ça va non bien sûr il j'essaye
et du goût de lui au début voilà mon
père il est très dur il pourra pas par
un trait carré et tout au début il m'a
dit tu vas pas me faire ça quoi et jésus
belge lem mais ils étaient horrifiés
maintenant ils s'apprécient beaucoup
donc chez face à l'amour on est je pense
obligé d'abdiquer critiques qui vous ont
blessés parfois ou pas du tout où des
mots des potes des amis de vos amis dit
elle disait quoi parce que c'est vrai
conduire ses copines voilà je suis avec
un quand vous aviez quand vous êtes vous
aviez donc 24 24 ans votre copine a
besoin d'imagés temps au cours florent
et où j'avais ma vie d'étudiante quoi et
c'est vrai que j'ai des copines qui me
disaient mais ma fille tu fais quoi mais
en fait ça m'a jamais vraiment blessé ça
m'a fait rigoler parce que moi de toute
façon je suis assez sûr de de mes choix
de ce que je regrette jamais vous avez
jamais regretté plus d'opposition mais
ce qu'elle sait rien
c'est donc vous avez fait le bon choix
oui bien entendu mais c'est vrai qu'il
peut y avoir des réflexions
désobligeantes même encore maintenant
alors que moi je trouve que la
différence d'âge se voit peut-être moins
parce que moi aussi je prends de l'âge
et et voilà et pourtant pour les jambes
il voit la différence d'âge encore
maintenant mon mari en rigolant une des
méthodes sur la jeune fille et moi
j'évite terry donc une dirigeante mais
on a été gentils mais du coup moi je
vois là j'ai appris à ne pas me
formaliser parce que je sais que
les gens sont dérangés des choses qui
les fascine et que je pense qu'il ya une
part de 2 non compréhension donc pas
forcément de jalousie mais il ya quelque
chose qui gêne quand on suit pas un
format qu'on nous vend depuis toujours
parce que les couples en général ils se
rencontrent voilà parfois même à la fac
tout ça donc nature on a dans
l'inconscient collectif qu'il faut avoir
le même âge et que ces voix là comme ça
qu'on fait 35 ans que de nombreuses
jeunes filles
au master
finance maintenant c'est vrai à la fac à
la minute avec tout ça